[Music]  standing on a football pitch makes me  feel like standing on top of the world  my main goal is to change the image we  have of an ideal footballer and secure  equal access to the playing field for  all females without us having to  compromise background religion or looks  [Music]  women are often second priority in  football and it doesn't get better when  we look at those of us who are  minorities in the game  as a football coach i'm challenging the  odds by creating opportunities for all  the females in my city  [Music]  europe has encouraged me to lead by  recognizing and supporting my  initiatives no matter what and no matter  where  [Music]  my main message to all the girls and  women out there is that one coach one  player and one ball can change the world  if we all aim for the same goal  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]